what if a YouTuber made a video in the
year 2100 about climate change would
they talk about how the global average
temperature Rose and then stabilized
would they talk about how the world
removed its dependence on fossil fuels
which climate tipping points were
reached how we overcame the climate
crisis the latest video on my YouTube
channel is exactly this a retrospective
from the year 2100 on a 21st century
which is not the best case scenario but
a version of the future in which we win
talking about why war broke out in
Central Asia in 2043 how the world found
the resources for the energy Revolution
and who was on trial in Acra Ghana in
2073 you can watch the most ambitious
project I've ever made global warming
the century we saved Earth right now on
YouTube or add free on nebula